l'avion médicalisé qui transportent
marie trintignant et sa mère nadine
vient d'arriver il ya quelques minutes à
l'aéroport du bourget l'actrice est
toujours dans le coma il durant l'après
midi
le chanteur du groupe noir désir a été
entendu par la police lituanienne de
façon lapidaire il a tenté d'expliquer
les circonstances du drame
agnès garder céline rousseau nadine
trintignant n'a que ses mains pour
protéger le visage de cette chambre
marie trintignant toujours dans le coma
quitte l'hôpital de vilnius où elle a
été maintenue artificiellement en vie
depuis dimanche
sur le tarmac l'attend un avion privé
qui doit la ramener à paris
si les médecins lituaniens ont un temps
refusé tout rapatriement ils ont fini
par accéder en début d'après-midi aux
voeux de la famille
sa famille souhaite malgré le caractère
est évidemment irréversible de son état
c'est assez triste à dire mais que
finalement si elle doit mourir soit en
france une autre épreuve les attendaient
déjà ce matin lors de la comparution au
tribunal de vilnius de bertrand cantat
chanteur du groupe noir désir amant de
marie trintignant auteurs présumés des
coups qui ont plongé l'actrice dans le
coma la laissant la nuit du drame
inanimé jusqu'au petit matin sans
alerter les secours
six heures trop tard il aurait fallu la
mener immédiatement mais les chirurgiens
lituanien a été formidable
serez vous inviter à mia et toute
l'équipe médicale l'ont suivi je les ai
vus faire tout ce qu'il pouvait je les
ai vus but et vous regardez
le procureur a réclamé un mois de
détention provisoire contre bertrand
cantat évoquant un crime grave
le musicien se d'abord tu longuement
avant de déclarer en quelques mots
seulement je vous demande pardon mais
c'est un accident
ce n'est pas un crime l'ambiance est
tendue alourdie par la présence de
photographes et cameramans à qui mon
livre le suspect le tribunal a
finalement décidé de son maintien en
détention jusqu'au 14 août
et selon le code pénal lituanien si
marie trintignant décède
l'auteur des coups pourraient être
inculpés condamnés à 15 ans de prison
ce soir la france n'a toujours pas fait
de demande d'extradition